this is how cold it's been these are
houses Frozen on the shores of Lake Erie
a street in ice sculpture
the temperatures have taken their toll
across North America
the reach of this bomb Cyclone has
extended across thousands of miles and
several days it has gripped millions of
people
Upstate New York continues to struggle
through the effects in the City of
Buffalo heavy machinery has been brought
in for Roadside Rescue while police and
force a driving ban nothing and no one
is going anywhere quickly it's been
tough because the driving ban is still
in effect for the City of Buffalo and so
we haven't really left our house in
about a week I know most of the stores
that have been open they have not been
able to get new deliveries of any goods
and so if people are able to go to
corner stores or supermarkets that have
been reopening the shelves are bare
fatalities have included people found in
their homes and stranded in their cars
there is a state of emergency but
there's anger at the State of Affairs in
New York state one arm of local
government is blaming another mayor's
not going to be happy to hear about it
but storm after storm after storm after
storm the city unfortunately is the last
one to be opened and that shouldn't be
the case
it's embarrassing tell you truth and if
we have to working with the state we
will find a way to get through these
storms quicker by taking over operations
if need be I know the mayor's probably
not thrilled to hear it I don't care
anymore I want it done did you buy it
did you buy it all right put it back put
everything back come on there have been
numerous reports of looting
these are pictures from a supermarket in
Buffalo
it is grim here and it isn't over
as temperatures pick up there are
dangers presented by this snow melting
in these quantities as they dig
themselves out they are digging in for
the prospect of floods to follow
James Matthews Sky News Washington